Good job. Now you know the names of the cells, but
usually instead of words in the cells we'll have numbers or data.
If this is the case, you'll have to copy and paste
the data from the shared Google spread sheet, into your own spreed
sheet in order to analyze it. let's get familiar with this.
To create your own spreed sheet go to your Google Drive. All
of this is also explained in the Instructor Note section. If
you're signed in to your Google email account, you should see a
bar at the top that looks like this. You can click Drive, or you can just go
to drive.google.com. Make sure you're signed in. From your
Drive, I suggest your first step should be to
create a new folder for this class. To do
that, click this icon here. Name this whatever you
want. Maybe just Statistics. After you name it, you
should see a Statistics folder appear in your drive.
You can use this folder to store all the
datasets you work with throughout this class. Click on
it. Once you're in your Statistics folder, you can
create a new spreadsheet by clicking this button and selecting
Spreadsheet. You should then have a new spreadsheet that
looks like this. Then you can copy and paste
the data that I provide, like this flight cost
data. You just click Cmd+c, or Ctrl+c if you're on
a PC. And then you go to your
spreadsheet and click Cmd+v or Ctrl+v. Now you're able
to analyze the data. I recommend either creating a
new spreadsheet for each new dataset. Or, create a
new sheet within this same sheet by clicking this
plus sign at the bottom. Then you'll have a
new sheet within the same spreadsheet, in which you
can input a different dataset. Then you could call
this spreadsheet something like Statistics Datasets. And rename each
sheet to what it is, and what lesson. For example, this is
fFight Cost data from lesson 15. Alternatively, within
your Statistics folder, you can just continue
creating new spreadsheets. And then naming the entire
spreadsheet the name of that dataset that
I originally provide you. Its up to you.